- [Homie] How can you decide what to do
when you're good at a lot of stuff?
- You pick one.
- [Homie] So you don't waste your time.
- [Homie] Well how do you
know which is the right one?
- You don't.
(laughter)
(clicking)
- How do you deal with the unknown?
- By recognizing I have no choice.
I think it comes down to perfection
and like trying to make
the right, perfect call
and I think that the right, perfect call
about nine out of 10
times is the fastest call.
So I tend to not overthink at all.
I'm very intuitive and most
of my business mistakes
have been to act too quickly
and then have to bail out.
I've found that speed trumps everything.
Too many people are
crippled by the right hire,
by the right meeting, I say,
work harder, work more efficient,
make more 15 and 30 minute meetings
that leave you more time to do more things
and create more opportunities
and don't be crippled
by choosing the right
opportunities or not.
(hip hop instrumental)
I believe one of the most
fascinating excuses in life
is that I'm so good at so many things
that I don't know which one to pick.
So many of you are not taking action
'cause you overthink it, you
overthink it, you overthink it.
I think the thing that bothers me is that
people are crippled by their options
and then actually aren't
doing anything in parallel.
They're lolly gagging while they decide.
If you're so good at so many things,
you'll pick one, you'll be good at that
and then you can do a bunch of things.
I'm doing a bunch of things.
You need to be doing,
you need to be executing.
So if there's three to four
tangible things going on in your mind,
you need to make sure your
internships, your free time,
and whatever you can do
to let you taste them
and get context around them
is what really matters.
I always say deploy your resources
that you can afford to lose.
A lot of you don't have the dollars.
I used to not have the dollars,
but I had my time.
Taking action is, especially
if it doesn't cost you
top money and it's just time,
is always a better answer
than pondering or thinking
or trying to decide if
this is going to work.
You don't know and one
of the smartest things
I do as an entrepreneur
and business person,
is I do things so I can understand
whether they work or not.
(hip hop instrumental)
There was never a day in my life
where I didn't have something
that I call the 80% of what I do.
What I think you need to figure out is
you gotta create at least one burger.
I've got four, right?
You need to have one.
You can go and have side dishes
and if your meat, if
your steak is perfect,
you'll always be able to absorb the losses
because there's smaller losses.
I think a lot of people just eat
the potato or the pickle or the onion.
Like I have the burger,
Wine Library, Vayner Media,
my personal brand, investing,
those are my burgers.
Because what the burger does is
it allows you to create
the wealth creation
or the financial stability
that allows you to go flirt.
And then when something
over here becomes bigger,
you can turn that into the main part
and that could be come the steak.
Too many people have all
side dishes and no steak.
(hip hop instrumental)
- Do you ever get anything wrong?
What do you do when you make a mistake?
- I get everything wrong, it's
just that I can't recall it
because one it's wrong, I'm
moving one to the next thing.
I passed on Uber twice.
When they were raising money
at a $4,000,000 valuation,
I passed even though
Travis is one of my boys
and I think is one of the best
entrepreneurs in the world.
Had I wrote a $25,000
check into that company
like I did the other companies,
it'd be worth $300,000,000.
- [Man] Jesus Christ.
- And you have to understand,
this is my homie, he's
acknowledging my book.
That's what you have to do
when you're playing the game,
that's what you have to understand
when you're an entrepreneur,
those misses are gonna come in my career.
I look at losing as a positive,
mainly because everybody
here doesn't like losing
'cause they're worried what other people
think about their loss.
I don't care what you
think about my losses.
My L is my L.
You're more than welcome
to leave a comment
and clown on me when I fail on something
when something doesn't work out,
I have good news for you.
I don't give a what you have to say.
I swear on my kid's health,
I'm obsessed with losing.
I love losing.
I love losing 'cause I know exactly
what you're thinking about my loss
and I can't wait to stick it
in you face when I come back.
(audience cheers)
Be more efficient with what you do
to allow you to do more things,
then you don't have to worry about the
subjective and non-controllable
like knowing what's good or great.
That's the recap.
(hip hop instrumental)